hello and welcome to the shiki-san show
where in this video I'm going to see if
I can answer the question why women live
longer than men and because I am a
scientist
I will mainly be doing this from a
scientific perspective and I thought one
of the best ways to do this would be to
try and relate some of these potential
reasons to the hallmarks of aging and in
particular we'll end up focusing a
little bit on nutrient signaling a bit
of mitochondria and also an information
so why have I decided to talk about why
women live longer than men well firstly
because let's be honest it's quite
interesting and while I thought it'd be
interesting considering mile a female
watch counts out the minimums but joking
aside it's interesting because if we can
understand the differences between the
genders it might provide an insight into
the mechanisms of aging itself and also
it kind of raises the awareness for
potential gender specific medicine or
even past night medicine but also for a
special reason and this is partly
because a long time ago now well long
for me back in 2013 I wrote an essay
about why women live longer than men and
let's just say that s/he did quite well
and I revisited it recently and it's
quite funny and I've contemplated about
sharing it but I'm still on the fence
about it because there's some very
interesting things that I write anyway I
think it's partly to blame for my
interest in this topic and for pursuing
biochemistry you say I have to thank the
essay title writer I suppose anyway
let's go on with the video explaining
why women live longer than men is no
simple task and in fact isn't something
that we fully understand yet and so
there are many environmental historical
cultural anthropological socio-economic
and genetic factors that might be at
play here obviously from my background
I'll talk mainly about the science but
firstly just so you clear the waters I
just want to reiterate that this is a
general trend that women generally live
longer than men and that's on average by
6 to 8 years and this is all data
collected by
world health organization and as you can
see written here life expectancy for
women also varies across regions and
income levels of countries but generally
this trend is seen across lifespan
however it's not all sunshine and
sprinkles for females because there's
also a mortality morbidity paradox that
will come back to a little bit later so
I did quite a bit of research for this
video and I found that that isn't
actually that much literature on it I
found two refused from 2016 both of
which I've linked down in the
description but yeah and there wasn't
that much on it which was kind of
interesting but anyway there's a couple
of things I just want to say to set the
scene and that's firstly obviously aging
takes a long time to study a lifetime in
fact and my point is is that we don't
fully understand why females living with
the mo males and this is an even really
helped by the fact that we can use model
organisms to try and understand the
aging process and that's partly because
humans are different to other species
including mammalian species in the fact
that gender differences in lifespan on
anonymous they vary depending on the
species so whilst African lions right
there and numerous monkeys show pattern
for females to be the longer lift gender
in naked mole-rats for example and some
species of mice they see that the males
outlive the females so it's quite
complicated and this makes studying the
model organisms or using them as a model
for human studies isn't as effective but
if we can understand that differences
then maybe these same differences could
be applied to understanding differences
in human longevity between the sexes and
also just a general caveat for using
model organisms is that often the cause
of death of those organisms differs
between these them and humans for
example humans generally die while the
most frequent causes of death in Western
societies tends to be cancer and heart
disease and interestingly studies have
shown that women are less likely to
succumb to most of the major causes of
death and so if you
at the top 15 causes of death in the
u.s. 13 out of 15 of them the rate of
death is higher in males than females
interestingly for streak it was found to
be the same and even more interestingly
the rates was higher for women for
outside Miss disease and so that kind of
relates back to this mortality morbidity
hypothesis which we will return to at
some point and this information came
from this table which is in one of the
references in a description if you can't
see it on here it's quite some more
thing anyway let's move on and start to
discuss some of the potential reasons
why women live longer than men so one of
the quasar found in the review was
humans are the only species in which one
sex is known to have a ubiquitous
survival advantage and while regardless
of whether the statement is actually
true the data I've shown you so far has
shown that generally there is a pattern
for females to live longer
so why and so I've broken it down into
different reasons one is the dual of the
hormones one is the city with nutrients
signaling differences and then there's
the asymmetric inheritance argument
started to do with both the sex
chromosomes and the mitochondria and
also a link to the guard's microbiome so
let's start with looking at the sex
hormones first so typically men have
higher levels of testosterone and
females have higher levels of estrogen
and one thing I didn't actually realize
was that estrogen those different
multiple estrogens there's Easter
oneisha die oh and each trial and
besides these sex hormones known to have
an impact on the reproductive system
there's also been studies have shown
into 6 the sex hormones have an effects
on the immune response and it's well
established that men are more
susceptible to many illness caused by
viruses bacteria parasites and fungi and
unfortunately we even have evidence from
this most recent pandemic to support
that and so why is that the case and why
is it related to hormones well part of
that is potentially GG the antioxidant
and anti-inflammatory properties of
estrogen
and say there's been several studies
that support this one in particular is
they took some macrophages a type of
immune cell and they gave Easter dial to
do cells and what they saw was a
reduction in the levels of
pro-inflammatory cytokines and so dis
included interleukin-1 beta interleukin
6 and TNF alpha and so from these
different studies two general statements
coming aids one is which
estrogen seems to be immune improving
and progesterone and after performing an
testosterone seems to be immune
suppressing boards pretty
well-established is in females who go
through menopause there is a rapid
reduction in the levels of estrogen and
so this now brings us back to this
mortality morbidity paradox which is
that women on average appear to be in
poorer health than men throughout adult
life and this isn't just limited to
Western societies and so one explanation
to explain this paradox could be
menopause and this rapid reduction in
estrogen levels and so there's been
various studies that have shown an
association between late onset of
menopause and a reduction in all causes
of morbidity and mortality and moreover
from this the females who have a later
onset of menopause also show lower
levels of these inflammatory factors in
their plasma such as inflation one beta
and in sleepin sex and this kind of
relates back to you potentially having
this lower amount of inflammation which
is the chronic inflammation that's
associated well it is one of the
hallmarks of aging and so I think the
impact of hormones beyond just the sex
hormones on the hallmarks of aging is
something that currently still is pretty
much and what's pretty
unexplored and could have some
interesting insights into the aging
process and speaking of hallmarks of
aging that brings us on to nutrient
sensing where high nutrient sensing is
associated with more growth and an
acceleration of the aging process so
there are many signaling pathways within
a cell but there are some very key
signaling pathways that are involved in
the response to the levels of nutrients
so the best way to understand that is by
me trying to draw out the diagram so
let's say we have a cell and this is the
cell membrane and outside are different
nutrients and also signaling molecules
such as the insulin growth factor and
this causes an intracellular response
that leads to the activation of a
protein called
M tall and M tall promotes growth and
being quite simplistic here it can
inhibit otology which is a cellular
recycling process whereby they can reuse
damaged proteins and there's other
proteins and forms in this process such
as sirtuins and also ampk and what you
may be familiar with are the different
types of interventions that can activate
or inhibit these different proteins and
so this includes metformin which may
function through ampk and also
resveratrol that activate certains and
rapamycin that inhibits mTOR and also
dietary restriction which prevents
overall this signaling pathway and so
many studies performed in mice have
looked at different genetic knockouts
with different components and these
signaling systems and they see different
differences in the impacts on males and
females as to who gets the greater
benefits and similarly studies have been
done with these different interventions
and the the impact in males and females
seems to differ so I guess the question
is why and this is also an important
question considering the hope to use
some of these interventions in the
future and so we can try and understand
this by thinking about the hierarchy
hierarchical nature of those nutrients
they're going pathway and so this brings
us onto the hypothalamic pituitary axes
which I think I was going to do a video
and I haven't currently but anyway to
understand this there's basically
factors that regulate the levels of this
igf-1 and other molecules that can
promote nutrient signaling and so one of
these is growth hormone
studies seems to suggest that estradiol
so estrogen reduces the sensitivity to
growth hormone whilst testosterone has
the opposite impact and so it could
again be these differences in the sex
hormones that can alter how intense the
nutrient signaling is which could
therefore alter the rates of the aging
again yeah I think this is these is very
early studies and that doesn't quite
explain why the females have the
morbidity paradox although again it
could come back to the onset of
menopause just multiple questions at the
moment now let's move on to some of the
asymmetry seen between males and females
and firstly let's look at the sex
chromosomes so what kind of defines a
female or a male some what comes down to
sex chromosomes with males having an X
and a Y chromosome and females
possessing two chromosomes and so the X
chromosome in the male comes from its
mother and so most females have two X
chromosomes one of the X is typically
silenced in each cell and which one
whether it's the one the X chromosome
from the dad or the mom that the calm
silent is pretty random and it's 50/50
which X is active across a female's body
and this x chromosome inactivation does
leave roughly around 1717 is partially
active and sued because of this partial
reactivation I suppose it's thought to
give females and advantage because they
have effectively a somewhat backup copy
of genes which the Y chromosome lacks
but even more interestingly studies have
looked at which chromosome has been
inactivated and this ratio seems to get
skewed as you age and so whilst that
might be because one X is better than
the other and it could be an advantage
the studies have shown that actually
centenarians tend to maintain their
ratio of 50/50 and so having this
capability of having both
chromosomes seems to be the fittest
strategy and so besides the inheritance
of sex chromosomes the inheritance of
mitochondria the organelle in your cell
which is the powerhouse of the cell the
mitochondria in your cells are inherited
by the egg so you actually comes from
your mother and mitochondria has its own
DNA it has its own set of genes although
it's so easy some of the nuclear genes
and so because it comes from the mother
I thought that maybe it has evolved or
been selected to be optimal in females
compares males I don't really couldn't
really find any evidence about that if
you please let me know because it's
quite interesting for dollars and other
studies seem to show you that some
mitochondrial mutations are more
beneficial in either when they're found
they're males or females so again
yeah there's probably more to be
explored that so let's move on to the
last discussion points which is the gut
microbiome so I've spoken about the gut
microbiome before because it is a very
interesting topic and what is
interesting about the gut microbiome is
that it seems to change in terms of the
abundance of the different bacterial
species throughout lifespan and so you
can see on this graph just some of the
changes and these changes occur for
arrowheads but also they seem to
fluctuate on a daily cycle and
interestingly differences in the gut
microbiome composition have falsely been
associated with different diseases and
some of these diseases include some of
the causes of death that we mentioned
earlier on such as outside missus ease
and cancer and obesity and also other
diseases as well such as autism and
depression so besides the gut microbiome
composition varying by age and also by
diets studies have also seen shown
differences by gender as well and so I
think that's another area that though
still needs further exploration and just
for a bit of a bonus
there's also genetic
mutations that seem to have potential
benefits when present and a female as
opposed to her male and as I mentioned
in a previous video when I looked at
aging clocks there was one clock that
used blood samples to try and determine
biological age and that itself seemed to
be influenced by sex and so clearly
there are some key differences in males
versus females that have or seemed to be
underpinning some of these hallmarks of
aging and that's very interesting if we
can understand what they are I just
don't think we're that quite yet but
anyway hope you've learned something and
as always thanks for listening